cela fait dix ans que julie travaille
ici d'abord chez alstom puis aujourd'hui
pour general electric
elle vient de l'apprendre j supprimera
1044 emplois dans le territoire de
belfort
l'espoir au moment du rachat on est
d'accord on était enfin avec n'y en a
que lui qui avait peur il y en a qui
pensait que ça allait redonner un bon
coup de fouet à la société et puis
peut-être
il est 16h hadji et une partie des
salariés sort de l'entreprise pour eux
c'est le choc
un quart des effectifs du site de
belfort va désormais disparaître
aujourd'hui j'ai 50 ans j'ai encore à
crédit sur le dos et aujourd'hui je me
retrouver au chômage et puis je dois je
encore crime et encore pendant dix ans
12 e jusqu'à ma retraite
c'est là haut si on met deux j'essaierai
de tous et ailleurs même si c'est pas
facile puisqu'il ya plus rien donc après
voilà heureusement ma femme travaille ça
va sauver un petit peu les meubles quoi
en 2014 lors du rachat de la branche
énergie alstom general electric avait
promis la création d'un millier
d'emplois
aujourd'hui c'est tout le contraire et
cela inquiète les élus locaux
nous comptons 150000 habitants et perdre
1000 50 emplois chez general electric
s'est autant d'emplois dans la sous
traitance c'est autant d'emplois aussi
dans le domaine du commerce et puis les
emplois indirects et 3000 emplois au
total sur notre département
véritablement c'est un coup dur
contactée par téléphone la direction
justifie son plan social
le groupe j power aurait subi une baisse
de 22% de son chiffre d'affaires en un
an suite à la chute mondiale du marché
du gaz